my grandparents and their generation
were not too different from light hairs
parents and grandparents the elderly
lakota of the 1850s in the face of the
white incursion and changes brought to
them were telling stories and reminding
their children and grandchildren to
remember the remember the trails they
had walked
handcrafting a bow out of ash is almost
allow lost art for the lakota
my grandfather taught me because his
father white tail feather and second
father
which is his stepfather henry tuhawk
taught him to make bows and arrows they
learned it from their fathers and
grandfathers
and the methods and process are the same
as those that were taught to light hair
exactly the same
each time i've had the opportunity to
make a bow
a thought invariably passes through my
mind this is the way it has been done
for hundreds of generations
i make my bows the same way crazy horse
did
that is only one of the many connections
i have with him as lakota boys
there's a great discussion somewhere in
this book where they're talking about
the elders and they're talking
specifically about change
and they're like hey
we used to use lances to hunt the
buffalo before we came up with bows and
arrows and we transitioned over that so
we've got to be ready
to change
as things as things come along and they
give that historical example and that's
a struggle isn't it when when we think
of valued traditions that we have in our
culture
like what what do we strive to hold on
to and and and what do we let go of as
we grow yeah and there's i i don't
remember if i'm gonna cover this or not
but i'll bring it up right now one of
those same types of discussions
they're talking about there's a time
when it's time to get on a new horse
and like the old horse isn't working
anymore you got to get on a new horse
and and that's a good expression to keep
in your mind because you're riding that
horse and it's starting to fade or it's
not able to do its job anymore you got
to get on a new horse even though you're
comfortable with your old horse even
though you that old horse has been good
to you it's not going to work out
anymore you got to be ready to
transition to the new horse